Speaker 1: All right. Having sort of
recovered from that wild interview,
let's look at a couple of other things. I
did want to just briefly go over some of the
assertions made by attendees at both of the Trump
rallies over the weekend, Saturday in Nevada and
Sunday in Arizona. In Arizona, there was a woman
who said something that it just sounds wrong to
say about a Trump speech. Listen to this.
Speaker 2: Okay. And what brought you out
to the Trump rally? President Trump, what are
you looking for, people? What are you looking
forward to see from him? Oh, my gosh. The unity
and the healing and just move on and we just have
to heal as a nation and come together again.
And the truth and the truth, if we want the.
Speaker 1: Unity and healing and certainly truth
are not common occurrences, common features of
a Trump rally. In fact, I just saw a list of at a
recent rally, there were about 40 different people
or organizations that Donald Trump attacked. But
it's interesting how you can really see in it
anything you want, even if it's not there.
One of the wackiest pre rally moments at the
Arizona rally was a woman doing her man. I
don't even know how to explain this. Doing
some kind of speed drawing of Jesus and
the host saying, you know, it is Sunday.
After all, it's a very spiritual moment.
Speaker 2: Oh, yeah. So is she. She's just
living her element. She's a beautiful woman,
painting for a large crowd of American patriot.
Speaker 5: And obviously they find a way.
Christina It's a spiritual moment for her
as well on this on this Sunday. On this Sunday.
It's this very spiritual moment that she's having
with us right now, and it's just beautiful.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So they the woman does seem
to be having some kind of an issue. Then
they then they interviewed a guy with a
Second Amendment, God's guns and guts shirt. And
this guy, he tells a sort of sad story of, for
some reason, having lost many friends recently.
Speaker 5: Also lost a lot of friends because
I'm a Trump fan. I don't understand it. But you
know what we're all for? We're all in for. Yeah.
Yeah. And you know what? We're going to pray for
those people who cannot open their eyes. Right.
And find out how great Trump is for this country
and Carrie Lake. And of course, you get the whole
roster of some great conservative Republicans who
represent the state. Yes, sir. Yeah. We're going
to get your Second Amendment as well. I love that
God's gun, guts, everything. Look at you. And you
know what? You got a cool haircut, I'm hoping.
Speaker 1: Yeah. I don't know if the guy is
serious, but it's a interesting
haircut nonetheless. But
just really, it's perplexing. How could this guy
possibly have lost any friends? And, you know,
what really strikes me about these interviews
is, you know, imagine you go up to a guy like
this and you say, hey, you know what? The
tariffs on China were actually not good
for the United States. And we imagine they go,
oh, you know what? That yeah, that's true. That
makes sense. These are folks that are so deep
down the rabbit hole that it just simply it
seems impossible. It seems impossible. Another guy
now going to the Nevada rally the previous day,
a guy at the Nevada rally had an
incredible conspiracy theory about
what's happening in Ukraine. Listen to this.
Speaker 5: And the thing that really makes
me mad about Ukraine, we put the bio weapon
labs under Obama and Obama said, oh, yeah,
we'll give it, give up the nukes and we got your
back. We helped causes with Ukraine under Obama.
So I understand why Russia is and you're doing
what you're doing with the whole de-Nazification
of the Donbas region, because so many Ukrainian
nationalists seem to be full blown Nazis these
days. A lot of media I've seen come out of
the Russians taken before them, but these
guys got swastikas all over them tattooed. I
like our media does like to play that though.
It's really interesting how that works. Yeah.
Speaker 1: You know, we've talked about this.
There is there's a small Nazi presence in Ukraine,
but this is just a completely whacked conspiracy
theory. Obama's really responsible because he
built bio labs in Ukraine and made Russia give
up nukes. And so that's what I mean. It's just
unhinged. And it's so it's wound up so tight that
I don't know how you undo it. Here's another woman
at the Trump rally who says she loves Putin. And
it's sort of like not exactly the message that
I think they're trying to associate with their
movement, but it is what it is.
Speaker 2: And but the Russia
and the Ukraine conflict. What's
your. Oh, my opinion. You know,
I grew up in 40 years, you
know, under the Russian thing.
And I love 14, but I love Putin. Is making
the right you know what? The American people
is built over there. He wants to clean them
out, you know. He wants to rid of America,
clean em out all da da da. Biochemical place,
everything and a nuclear thing. Yeah. We'll
have to talk more about this because he's a
good, good president. You know, number two,
after president won. Number two.
Speaker 1: Yeah. I mean, listen, this
is these are the these people gravitate towards
authoritarian autocrats. And so they really do see
Trump and Putin or Putin as similar. And it's not
exactly the message that right side broadcasting
and all these different networks want to want to
put out there and portray. But it is accurate. It
is. It is what it is. Here's just one last one.
This one's from the also the Nevada rally. Here's
a woman who just talks again about all the things
she likes about Trump and none of them are true.
Speaker 2: I love him. And I think he's he's
the kindest, gentlest man. He listens and he's
not a bully like they try to, you know, and he's
mean, but he's absolutely I mean, just look at
his children. They don't smoke. They don't drink.
President Trump, I mean, he did something right.
Speaker 1: So there's a perspective and I
guess maybe the most false claim in there is
he's not a bully. I mean, it's hard to think of a
bigger bully. So. Are these folks beyond reach? Is
it beyond repair? Is are they too far gone? Let
me know what you think and then we will follow
up. It's the perpetual question as at least as
far as it affects elections, we care about it.